- You can smell their breath,
I know you're big on dog breath so
- Aw man I love it so
much, waft it over here.
- Today we're going to
be guessing dog breeds.
- No!
- Like we don't get to see the dog?
- Oh that's so much harder.
- Blindfolded.
- Like hey man what're you tossing at me,
is this a dog or something?
(cheerful music)
- Oh my gosh! (laughs)
- It's naked.
(record scratch)
It's soft!
- A very long snout.
- Oh, it's furry!
- Is that a cat or like
a rat or something?
(buzzer)
Is this a joke?
Is that a giant rat?
- Is it a Dachshund?
(bell dings)
- I think she's a wiener doggy.
- Oh, totally.
- It is a Dachshund.
Yes!
- Nice!
- She loves you.
- Here, can you do it?
- Aw, Olivia you're awesome.
- Like I think the features of that dog
were pretty easy to guess.
- The long body, the short hair.
- I'm actually feeling
better about this now.
- Hi!
You got a dog?
- Yeah, oh so soft.
- Oh you're a big guy,
you're like a really big guy.
- Yeah you're a big old buckaroo there.
- He's got tiny little ears.
- Tiny little ears, what the
hell is going on with this dog?
- Little bit courser fur.
- Good little belly, good tush.
- Yeah, it's a corgi.
(buzzer)
- I would know a corgi, it's not a corgi,
it has short little ears.
- I swear to god if it's a
fox or something like that,
cause that would be really cool.
Is it a fox?
(buzzer)
- Oh my god.
- It's a Shiba.
- I'm gonna pull it off, I'm confident.
Oh nah, oh you have such a fat Shiba.
- Oh it's a Chiquita or a shinaba, Shiba.
(bell dings)
- Yeah the short little snout,
short little ears, no tail.
She's a beauty.
- You're literally the doge.
- We got two for two, we
are dog breed masters.
- Let's guess more fur babies.
- Alright alright we're
dealing with a lot of fur,
this is a golden retriever.
(buzzer)
- Oh it's big, this is a big one!
- Is this a golden retriever?
What if it's a golden retriever.
(buzzer)
- Yeah, I'm gonna go with a retriever.
- I don't know, this is like a bear.
(buzzer)
- Is it a husky?
- Ooh stylish, I feel a bandana.
I feel like we have a similar style.
- He smells pretty good for a dog.
- I think I'm wrong, I think this might be
some kind of a wolf.
(buzzer)
- Maybe it's a wolf dog
from Game of Thrones.
- It's practically a wolf dog.
- He's like the dire wolf that
you get in Game of Thrones.
- Like ghost?
- Yeah.
- Whoa it's black!
- Aw man I think I got it.
- I thought it was tan.
- Can I get a kiss?
Oh kisses!
- That was quite the experience.
- A day that starts with doggies
is a day that's okay with me.
- I think when you're put to the test,
your dog breed knowledge
will surprise you.
- I don't mind dog breath.
Dog breath is good.
- What?
- Yeah, it's good.
Just one man's opinion.
Dog breath is good.
(cheerful music)